if you're in a crowded marketplace and
you want to stand out you want to win
the clients then you need to find a way
to be unique to be different so that you
become a destination site where people
will take longer to drive to you will
spend more money with you because they
want to do business with you over
everybody else hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today I mention a
question from a reader mega who wrote in
hi Evan hope you're doing good I want to
thank you for all the inspiration
articles you've mailed me thank you no
problem it's always really helped insert
in a lot of ways long email basically
she works at an agency and is
representing a beauty salon and is
trying to think of ways that the beauty
salon can grow their business beauty
salons competitive industry there's a
lot of beauty salons what you didn't
tell me here is about what is different
about this beauty salon instead of
fighting the battle that most beauty
salons face which is either on price or
on location or both right you're
competing with the other beauty salons
in your area and people only go so far
they pick the closest one or the
cheapest one that's not the game you
want to play you have to be different
what is so different about your beauty
salon that will make people travel
further and spend more money just to be
with you
why would somebody drive an hour to get
to your beauty salon why would somebody
pay five times as much as normal prices
to be with you that's what you need to
figure out that's your marketing that's
how you grow it you have to be known as
the beauty salon that helps X helps
these people help solve this problem
what's so special differently unique
about you and that's got to come across
in all your marketing right when you
write in an email to say I have a beauty
salon it doesn't tell me anything
how many beauty salons are out there
tons what's your competition tons
everybody's doing the same thing the
opportunity to stand out is tremendous
there's no differentiation between these
guys it's usually just who's closest and
you're pulling from your local market
and if there's one that's close to you
then it's whoever has the cheapest price
typically you can't play that game
have to change it you need to be the
only beauty salon that does a certain
thing you're the best in the world at it
and people will drive an hour and spend
five times as much money because they
want to be with you so what is that that
becomes the core of all your marketing
word-of-mouth will spread like wildfire
because people will tell their friends I
went to this place because they do this
that's the hook you got to figure out
and it can't just be a marketing angle
can't just be a PR angle it's got to be
part of the business you have to
genuinely do this you need to have that
thing about your business that makes you
stand out and it may already be there I
don't know about the owner I don't know
why they started their business I don't
know what makes them different what
their passion is what else they could
bring to the company but you have to
figure that out you have to talk your
client and figure that out because
that's going to be the best way to build
the business and forget about the
advertising and the radio eyes or
marketing whatever you whatever else you
had in mind those are all just band-aid
solutions you're fighting a losing game
you have incremental growth tiny growth
and you'll spend a lot of money doing it
the way to stand out is to be totally
different
be the best in the world at something
and make it something that people will
drive and spend more money to be with so
figure out that angle let me know what
it is good luck
for those are you watching you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
always going to do more for you and I
want to hear from you please leave a
comment end of this video about this
topic or question that you have for your
own business and I'd love to try to
answer it for you it really makes my
morning every time I see comments come
in so thank you guys and I'll see you
soon
you